hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey Big
O Lord sir King's van trailer today exit
official trailer number two we might as
well just do it right now
[Music]
which is all to see this is going to be
fun if you like that they form color
blind as well as burns you have no idea
of what they're capable of
other ways of doing your duty you're
going to need a suit it's deer it in
style
we are the first independent
intelligence agency preserving peace and
protecting life hey Daniel Bruhl for us
butan
[Music]
who's that actor that's everybody
reputation is what people think of me
[Music]
they're ready we shall see
it's called a parachute it means that
one can jump out of a plane safely
[Music]
Oh crazy that actually that looks pretty
fun
well one felt more like Kingsman yeah
actually put the watt light Kingsman if
you think about its similar plots yeah
thinking that during this a very similar
plot setup it's also kind of men in
black which you know Kingsman is already
like men in black and James yeah a bunch
of other things
weirdly this trailer just grabbed me
more like I liked the vibe of the
setting of the first one like I thought
that was neat but this one actually made
me excited about the idea of seeing this
man well I could see how it's more
tonally a kid into something like
Kingsman the teaser trailer or the first
trailer for this one was just like an
epic World War one movie yeah I'm like
this looks very kind of serious but I
almost have like a Kingsman take on like
Valkyrie or some you're alright and well
I think there's probably gonna have to
be a little bit more serious moment here
because you're dealing with a real world
war that did occur I still feel like
there's gonna be those character moments
especially like movement like them the
way the scene ended like this is cold a
parachute yeah yeah and making a gimmick
out of him like not able to smoothly
eject himself out of a plane that's like
flavor I think this movie could actually
have that does set it apart from its
predecessors and and that could make it
distinct because you know the Kingsmen
movies are ripping off James Bond in a
way so you have all this like very
advanced technology so it's gonna be
funny I would imagine if they use that
throughout the movie to see what is
advanced for that time and then what
stuff you know has yet to be invented
that we think is pretty primitive well
maybe that parachute joke will pop up
throughout and I don't know how much of
this will even mean the actual movie
itself but I really like how the
marketing for this movie hasn't relied
on Easter eggs of the original the
original yeah yeah it's like yeah you do
got to go to the spa where there's you
know the Kingsmen this is the shop
outside that's just part of the plot
it's part of the Kingsmen world that
makes some sense but there's nothing
here where they're making any jokes or
references or maybe they just flew way
over my
pursue through this guy's gonna be
eggsy's grandpa or something and then
you know it'll all tie it I'll be the
chosen one I'll be okay with that in the
end maybe Michael Caine's character will
appear in some way in a young form hey I
mean I mean that would make sense
imagine we might we might perhaps meet a
lot of young future yeah this does make
me flash too when Matthew Vaughn decided
to helm x-men first class yeah I love
what I'm seeing you really love Djimon
Honsou yeah I love that he's actually
getting some real time to shine it he's
always casting these comic-book movies
and Farrelly doesn't anything no he's
not such training he's also fighting
someone I'm like okay guys he's got real
scenes in this movie yo it looks like at
least from the few glimpses of them all
inside the tailor shop never yeah it
looks like he is one of their squad you
know this does appear I mean I know it
looks like you have your sort of n
protagonist with the young guy but it
seems like this is more of an ensemble
piece than the Kingsmen movie like I
feel like the Kingsmen movies are about
eggsy and this feels like you're gonna
have a new guy getting to know the ropes
but the vibe I'm getting off this
trailer is a bit more ensemble oriented
like anyone's gonna kind of play a big
part the trailers both have still been
consistently selling on the time period
in the world and a hint at their
characters I have yet to have a moment
though sounds like such a pompous
reviewer I've yet to experience a moment
with the Kingsmen tripping yes we are
I've yet to have a moment where I feel
really like oh that character is the one
I'm really gonna be hooked into because
I remember even with the first Kingsman
movie you could tell like Colin Firth is
gonna kick ass yeah they're like comfort
is gonna be awesome in this and then the
movie really is more about actually than
it is Colin Firth and welcomes our first
has that working for him words like Oh
totally he gets tight yes yes that is
true but I still had a moment where I
felt I could latch onto a character and
adhere I'm excited about the world and I
trust Matthew Vaughn a lot like he and
I've loved the last couple Kingsman
movies so a lot of that built in faith
is really getting me and I know there's
been a lot of positive response to the
marketing of this film thus far I've yet
to have any a moment what with any of
the marketing of where I'm really hooked
into any of the characters and I really
hope that there's one of these guys will
truly show because you know that's one
thing that Kingsman movies I think so
crisis with us how much we cared about
eggsy and and what gala is he Lancelot
Galahad Harry Harry Harry yeah oh you're
thinking of Marcos drums no Marx Marx
runs Merlin yeah yeah Harry oh yeah I'm
with you in the sense that I'm not fully
latched on to anybody in this trailer
yet although I did get like a modicum
closer because this tree lines ray
Fiennes yeah because he's bringing in
that you know that weird smooth elegance
he's able to do like this almost reminds
me of like this could be Gustave H is
cousin you know who kicks a lot more ass
I'd appreciated that moment about
reputation being what everybody thinks
about you versus character being what
you truly prove of yourself in that
moment where he's carrying that guy over
the battlefield not just gentle men
exactly but you know I mean that at
least got me closer to thinking okay
maybe that character could have a moving
arc that I could get into you know I
feel like a lot of people I've seen
online be very excited about his casting
so I just haven't seen most of the stuff
he's into bi I'm with you but I'm sort
of getting this sense for like this
trailer brought me more personality
overall and it also felt a little more
comic book especially because you had
way more like gas mask dudes and secret
lab stuff right the guy I don't know if
he's Rasputin or if he just looks like
Rasputin but you know this guy being all
devious and maniacal and grabbing people
with needle guns you know like it
definitely looked more sci-fi than the
first trailer I guess to me and while
you were talking and I wasn't listening
I looked up the actor's name who plays
this Rasputin like character oh hey it
is I'd never learned his name but I
loved him when I see him Rhys Ifans
okay who's in my favorite romantic
comedy Notting Hill and he's also my
favorite sports movie The Replacements
oh damn look a field goal yeah and he's
and I was a bad guy a fighter man was
fun to make yeah that's right yeah the
makeup on him was so good that I didn't
register him at first
ya know
how is it that the thing is here like
those eyes I familiar like I know it's
not Oscar Isaac when I was thinking more
of that sort of act he looks like he's
having a blast playing whoever he's it
looks like we got a really cool villain
on our hands too I'm sure there's gonna
be some type of political intelligent
villain as well but he looks like he's a
like the the main person of fear based
off how this trailer is going whereas in
the first two Kingsman movies there
people were just the brain so they have
other people who are the muscle looks
like our villain main focal villain is
the muscle as well okay so I think
that's a cool difference to add anywho
brains and bronze guys are you excited
for this are you hoping this heavily
ties into the first Kingsman movie you
know how well you remember that film all
of us do cinema eating middle mmm guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell comp below
and tell us what your favorite suit to
wear is now or if you're a lady what
your favorite bikini suit it's a bold
new world they're gonna see them
invented in this kings man move paid for
the day shout out to Jenn Schmitt Jenn
and the Holograms Jennifer how are you
my dear
I haven't spoken you in a while and by a
while and Gregg and Jenn standards that
is one week on patreon message hey
what's going on I hope you and your son
are doing well son wants to start up his
own YouTube channel swords he should if
you want advice always read the comments
that's the best way to go about life
keep reading the comments about you
helpful feed and I only delete the
positive ones because you need the Crim
you don't want to get any creation rides
on tension yes also base up the line of
work you've told me you you've delved
into a lot I'm sure you yourself have a
great suit and a good bikini as well
sure which you can wear them both your
son is just like being really happy to
see you haven't really we cut after that